when charlize theron played megan kelly
in bombshell the makeup team had to
change the very structure of theron's
face right down to her nose
makeup artist kazuhiro gave therin two
hidden nose plugs tailored to widen her
nostrils to match kelly's face
it's just one of the many details
productions tackle when transforming
actors into real public figures because
unlike fictional characters audiences
already know what these characters look
like so they can easily catch any
mistake
rummy malik's oscar-winning portrayal of
freddie mercury in bohemian rhapsody
needed to capture one very unique
physical feature the queen front man's
iconic teeth
so malik wore fake teeth to account for
mercury's additional four incisors and
the teeth had to be adjusted and resized
perfectly so they didn't change the way
malik talked
since mercury was a performer malik also
had to move and dance on stage the way
mercury did to achieve this malek worked
with movement director polly bennett
first they studied mercury's past and
learned that he was both a boxer and
long distance runner so mullet trained
himself to be agile and limber like a
boxer with this boxing background
mercury could change direction very
quickly on stage and so too could malik
meanwhile the film wanted to recreate
live aid nearly shot for shot meaning
malik had to imitate every frame of the
concert footage you can see malik
perfectly match how mercury handles the
mic here and how he struts around on
stage here
the makeup team behind bombshell had
just six weeks of pre-production to make
charlie's therin look like megan kelly
luckily theron didn't need heavy
prosthetics for her transformation
instead the team focused more on subtle
differences far beyond the nose plugs we
mentioned earlier
first theron and kelly have very
different shaped eyes so makeup artist
vivian baker turned to fake eyelashes
using lashify gossamers which come in
pieces instead of a single strip
this flexibility gave baker the ability
to play with the weight of theron's
lashline with the addition of fake
eyelids this transformed her eyes
according to makeup artist kazuhiro from
deep socketed to more hooded
to get a deeper shade of blue to match
kelly's eyes theron wore colored contact
lenses and to match what the makeup team
described as kelly's heart-shaped face
the team lowered theron's wig thus
lowering her hairline
hiro also created some traditional
prosthetics as well like an upturned
nose tip an angular jaw and chin pieces
actor gary oldman looks nothing like
winston churchill so when the actor was
cast to play churchill in darkest hour
makeup artist kazuhiro had to cover
oldman in nearly half his body weight
worth of special effects makeup
they did about three to five makeup
tests matching various silicone
prostheses to see what was crucial and
what wasn't hiro realized he could cover
oldman's cheeks jowls neck chin and nose
but oldman's eyes mouth and forehead
were important for emphasizing
expressions and emotions so hiro
intentionally left out some of
churchill's physical features like
discarding the piece for churchill's
real-life forehead scar that's why you
can see oldman's real forehead creases
emote as much as his mouth the team made
up for this diversion from the truth by
nailing details the viewer might not
even think of as essential
like giving the prosthetic pieces pink
and blotchy tones to match the leader's
skin
in the end even without the scar darkest
hour created a convincing churchill
leading to oscar wins for both oldman
and hiro
as seen in itanya visual effects can be
just as crucial to an actor's
transformation as makeup and training
margot robbie trained for five months to
skate like tonya harding but there were
multiple moves too difficult for a
non-olympic athlete and since harding's
skating routines are just as famous as
her public persona the film had to get
the moves exactly right so the team used
two vfx methods to seamlessly combine
robbie's training with her stunt doubles
for the first method a stunt double
would skate with an orange tennis ball
on her head her face would be swapped
out for robbie's
the second method was full head
replacement they 3d scanned robbie's
face to get a full range of her skin
texture and expressions in order to
build a digital model head replacement
was useful for complex shots like this
one which was actually three shots
stitched together because of this
careful work behind the scenes you'll
never be able to tell what part of the
shot is robbie and what part is a double
instead you can just focus on how robbie
imitated all of harding's mannerisms
from putting her hand over her face when
she's upset to raising her arms in a
moment of triumph
in rocketman the first step to
transforming taryn edgerton into elton
john was nailing the costumes especially
when edgerton was performing
after all jon himself said he doesn't
feel like the elton john until he
chooses his outfit for a show so costume
designer julian day closely modeled
edgerton's looks after john's real
outfits
this included designing 50 pairs of
glasses and 50 pairs of shoes one of
which was covered in real swarovski
crystals and while edgerton already knew
how to sing playing an instrument in
elton john's legendary style is a whole
other skill
edgerton spent six weeks training with
piano coach michael l roberts according
to roberts a piano is hard to perform at
since you can't move around with it like
you would with a guitar so edgerton
focused on the unique parts of john's
playing style such as how he leans into
his mic and sometimes plays with his
feet
roberts and edgerton also studied john's
musical influences like blues and boogie
woogie to get the right style of finger
placement
because of that physicality it really
felt like you were watching elton john
play
[Music]
you